This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I don't trust anyone who doesn't love a good map. Even something as everyday and basic as a Rand McNally road atlas could occupy me for hours in the backseat of a hot car. But if you want my eyes to literally dilate with excitement, show me a 3D physical scale model of a city. There's one of these in San Francisco, a 41 by 37-foot scale model of a city that was created in the late 1930s and then lost for decades. It was recently unearthed, refurbished and distributed in pieces to neighborhood libraries. I had heard about this crazy model years ago. Some cryptic allusion to it, maybe in the Chronicle,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我不信任任何不喜欢好地图的人。哪怕是像兰德·麦克纳利公路地图集这样日常而基础的东西，也能让我在闷热汽车的后座上消磨几个小时。但如果你想让我兴奋得瞳孔放大，那就给我看一座城市的 3D 实物比例模型。旧金山就有一个这样的模型，一个 41乘37 英尺的城市比例模型，创作于 20 世纪 30 年代末，随后失踪了几十年。它最近被出土、翻新，并被分块送到各个社区图书馆。多年前我听说过这个疯狂的模型。某些隐晦的提及，可能是在《纪事报》上，
they'd just said there was this enormous scale model of San Francisco that once was on display briefly and then vanished, the idea that there was a miniature world. It's something just so irresistible to your childlike brain. This model of the city is a tangible 3D roadmap through time and space. Triggering stories from San Francisco's past, realities of the present, and visions of the future. These stories were collected by the kitchen sisters,
他们只是说，旧金山曾经有过这样一个巨大的比例模型，短暂展出过，然后就消失了，这种存在一个微型世界的想法。对你孩子般的头脑来说，这是无法抗拒的。这个城市模型是一张贯穿时空的有形 3D 路线图。它唤起了关于旧金山过去的种种故事、现在的现实以及对未来的构想。这些故事由厨房姐妹（The Kitchen Sisters）收集，
Davian Nelson and Nikki Silva, and produced into the gorgeous audio collage we're going to play for you today. Here's Nikki Silva. Our story begins with this gigantic handmade model made up of over 6,000 tiny carved buildings and bridges forgotten for almost 80 years. It involves artists, curators, poets, planners, and a mega collaboration between SF-MOMA and 29 branches of the San Francisco Public Library. This object has become the catalyst for over 100 public programs throughout San Francisco. It's activated bicycle tours.
戴维安·纳尔逊（Davian Nelson）和妮基·席尔瓦（Nikki Silva），并被制作成我们今天要播放的精彩音频拼贴。这是妮基·席尔瓦。我们的故事从这个巨大的手工模型开始，它由 6000 多个微小的雕刻建筑物和桥梁组成，被遗忘了近 80 年。它涉及艺术家、策展人、诗人、规划师，以及旧金山现代艺术博物馆（SF-MOMA）与旧金山公共图书馆 29 个分馆之间的大规模合作。这个物件已成为在旧金山举办 100 多个公共项目的催化剂。它带动了自行车之旅。
It's lured in thousands of locals and tourists and historians, triggered people's memories, and generated questions and ideas about how we can go forward as a city, keeping it dynamic and diverse and just and hospitable, protecting the environment, a pretty tall order for an object. Welcome to San Francisco, stories from the model city. Oh, okay, the 1938 model was made to the scale of 1 inch to 100 feet. Where considerable carving was required, popular and sugar pine were the woods used. Shrebery growing on the map is made of wire wool, pieces of sponge, and beat seeds. I'm Stella Lachman, associate for public dialogue at the San Francisco Museum of Modern Art and the current keeper of the model.
它吸引了成千上万的本地人、游客和历史学家，触发了人们的记忆，并引发了关于我们如何作为一座城市继续前进的问题和构想——保持其活力、多样性、公正和热情，保护环境——对一个物件来说，这要求可真不低。欢迎来到旧金山，来自模型城市的种种故事。哦，好的，1938 年的模型是按 1 英寸比 100 英尺的比例制作的。需要大量雕刻的地方，使用的是黄松和糖松木。地图上生长的灌木丛是用钢丝绒、海绵块和甜菜种子制作的。我是斯特拉·拉克曼（Stella Lachman），旧金山现代艺术博物馆公共对话专员，也是该模型的现任守护者。
Three-quarters of a century of different keepers for this thing. It's a very big object to keep. The entire model, when it's reassembassembled is almost 40 by 40 feet, absolutely colossal. I'm Dr. Gray-Brecchan, Geographer of ETC Berkeley. I was alerted that this model existed by some of the custodians at the UC warehouse. Fortunately, they didn't dumpster it. The reason for building it was to put a lot of people to work during depression.
四分之三个世纪以来，这个东西经历了不同的守护者。这是一个非常大的需要保管的物件。整个模型重新组装后有近 40 乘 40 英尺，绝对是庞然大物。我是加利福尼亚大学伯克利分校的地理学家格雷·布雷坎（Gray Brechin）博士。加大约仓库的一些管理员提醒我，这个模型是存在的。幸运的是，他们没有把它扔进垃圾箱。建造它的原因是为大萧条时期提供大量就业机会。
1200 man months of labor according to the WPA records, about 35 people working every week for two years. The other thing was to create this model as a planning and educational tool that would always be on public display. This took place during the 1930s when the city was being completely transformed by the New Deal Public Works projects. The two bridges, the East Shore Freeway, the airports, Treasure Island, this model, it's a three-dimensional freeze frame of what the city was like at the time of the Treasure Island World's Fair just before Pearl Harbor. At the time of the World's Fair,
根据 WPA（公共事业振兴署）的记录，有 1200 个月的人工工时，大约 35 人连续两年每周工作。另一个原因是将这个模型打造为一个规划和教育工具，并将其永久向公众展出。这发生在 20 世纪 30 年代，当时这座城市正被新政公共工程项目彻底改造。两座桥梁、东岸高速公路、机场、金银岛，这个模型是金银岛世博会（珍珠港事件前夕）时城市风貌的三维定格。在世博会期间，
the model city, featuring every single structure in every single neighborhood, was still under construction. But there's a photograph of 11 women wearing Ingrid Bergman-style hats and capes lined up along a finished portion of the model, on display for the first time in 1939 on Treasure Island. Here is a green come true, the Golden Gate International Exposition on Manmade Treasure Island. Treasure Island is an artificial island, named after the Robert Louis Stevenson Island, made by piling up sand and rocks in the bay, created for the great international exposition, the world's fair of 1939-1940,
这个模型城市展示了每一个街区的每一个建筑，当时仍在建设中。但有一张照片显示，11 名头戴英格丽·褒曼风格帽子、身披斗篷的女性，排成一列站在模型已完成的部分旁，于 1939 年在金银岛首次展出。这里是一个梦想成真的地方，金门国际博览会在人造金银岛上举行。金银岛是一个人工岛，以罗伯特·路易斯·史蒂文森岛的名字命名，是通过在海湾中堆积沙子和岩石建造的，为 1939-1940 年的大型国际博览会即世博会而创建，
sort of a UN-like feeling, the brotherhood of Pacific nations. I'm Gary Camea, author of Cool Gray, City of Love, 49 Views of San Francisco. It shimmering reflections bring beauty from the sky. The whole world's fair concepts were kind of psychedelic, fantastic, made up architecture, an enormous courts and incredible lighting, and the model would be a perfect fit for Treasure Island, the whole city in one room. Angel Island. At the same time that there was this exuberant world's fair, probably less than a mile away as the
有一种类似联合国的感觉，太平洋国家兄弟会。我是加里·卡梅亚（Gary Camea），《酷灰色，爱之城：旧金山的 49 种视角》的作者。它波光粼粼的倒影带来了来自天空的美丽。整个世博会的概念有点迷幻、奇幻，虚构的建筑，巨大的庭院和不可思议的灯光，这个模型非常适合金银岛，整个城市尽在同一个房间里。天使岛。在这个充满活力的世博会同期，直线距离可能不到一英里之外，
crow flies, Angel Island, the largest island in the bay, was being used as an immigration and quarantine point. A place where Chinese immigrants were detained and often deported and not allowed into the country. My name is Jenny Lim. I'm a poet, playwright, second generation Chinese-American born and raised in San Francisco. My father was detained on Angel Island. And the play I wrote, Paper Angels, one of the characters Lomb, was kind of like a romanticized depiction of my father. They're in this jail-like barrack. They looked out the window.
海湾最大的岛屿天使岛，正被用作移民和检疫站。一个中国移民被拘留、经常被驱逐出境且不被允许进入这个国家的地方。我出生并成长于旧金山，是一名第二代华裔美国人、诗人兼剧作家珍妮·林（Jenny Lim）。我的父亲曾被关押在天使岛。我写的剧作《纸天使》（Paper Angels）中，有个叫朗姆（Lomb）的角色，有点像是我父亲的浪漫化写照。他们在这个像监狱一样的营房里。他们看着窗外。
You can see the water, the lights, within grasp, and it's unreachable. LUM talks about wanting to go to the expo and where his panima had. Walking down the streets, his best suit, and you know all the women ogling him because he looks so desirable. He's going to make his mark in this new country. He can imagine this exposition fare that shows all the best that this country has to offer an immigrant. The other guys are just saying, I'll go on, you know, big talker.
你可以看到水面、灯光，触手可及，却又遥不可及。朗姆谈到想去看博览会，戴着巴拿马草帽。走在街上，穿着他最好的西装，你知道所有的女人都在向他抛媚眼，因为他看起来那么有吸引力。他要在新国家崭露头角。他能想象这个世博会展示了这个国家能向移民提供的一切最好的东西。其他人则说，得了吧，你这个夸夸其谈的人。
You're never gonna achieve all those things. And in the story, he actually is the one that escapes. We never find out whether he makes it to sure or not. Some things we haven't found are these little ships that are going under the bay bridge. The model city was built in 1938 to 1940, on view at City Hall till 1942. At that point it was boxed up. Planning department would occasionally take pieces out to do studies on and when they no longer wanted it.
你永远也实现不了那些事情。而在故事中，他实际上是那个逃脱的人。我们永远不知道他是否成功抵达了岸边。我们还没有找到的一些东西是那些正在海湾大桥下行驶的小船。模型城市建于 1938 年至 1940 年，在市政厅展出至 1942 年。当时它被装进箱子里。规划部门会偶尔拿出其中的碎片来进行研究，当他们不再需要它时。
It was given to UC Berkeley as a teaching tool. But most of it was in these 17 wooden crates, sort of put in Higgledy Piglety. The model was hidden away until an artist duo based in Rotterdam heard about it. They'd been invited by SFMOMA to create an art project, engaging community and civic imagination. These Dutch artists, this couple called Big Van der Pol, had this great idea. Like, let's get that map, they heard about it, and let's get it out of storage and let's see if we can bring it back to life and make it part of the city's experience again.
它被作为教学工具赠予了加州大学伯克利分校。但其中大部分都装在 17 个木箱里，乱七八糟地堆放着。这个模型一直被藏匿着，直到鹿特丹的一个艺术家双人组听说了它。他们应旧金山现代艺术博物馆的邀请创作一个艺术项目，旨在让社区和公民发挥想象力。这对被称为维斯·范德波尔（Big/Yos van der Pol）的荷兰艺术家夫妇有一个绝妙的主意。比如，让我们去拿那张地图——他们听说了这件事——让我们把它从仓库里拿出来，看看是否能让它复活，并让它重新成为城市体验的一部分。
My name is Liesbett Bigg, I'm an artist, I live in Rotterdam, and I work with Yos van der Polg. I'm a Yos van der Polg Ik ben de jost van de Paul, een paar van de Paul. 30 peels gaan naar 30 gebieden van de brandstrijden. We willen organiseren discussie over de model. Not only nostalgia. Maar voor example, voor de huizen, sea level rising. Omlusneus. Issues van public space, citizenship.
我叫利斯贝特·比格（Liesbett Bigg），是一名艺术家，住在鹿特丹，我与约斯·范·德·波尔（Yos van der Pol）合作。我是约斯·范·德·波尔（Yos van der Pol）。30个区块将进入火灾部门的30个地区。我们希望组织关于该模型的讨论。不仅仅是怀旧。比如，还有关于房屋、海平面上升的问题。有关公共空间、公民身份的议题。
Hoe maak je deze issues discussiebalen, while looking at where you are? The model is really triggered to the whole project. Everything fell together. There is an historic layering, fantasy opens up, imagination opens up,
如何在审视你所在位置的同时，让这些议题变得可以讨论？这个模型真的是整个项目的触发点。一切都水到渠成。这里有一种历史的层叠，幻想被打开了，想象力被打开了，
other stories in that model start to sort of move around. Lawrence, brilliant daddy. It's an old myth going all the way back several centuries of San Francisco, Lauren Spirlinggetti. It's an old myth going all the way back several centuries of San Francisco as an island. We're surrounded by water on three sides and with the melting of the icebergs, the water will rise just a few feet or even a foot or two and it'll flood over the very low lying landmass between San Francisco and the San Francisco Peninsula. And then San Francisco will be an island again.
那个模型中的其他故事开始四处流转。劳伦斯，辉煌的爸爸。这是一个有着好几个世纪历史的旧金山古老神话，劳伦斯·斯皮林盖蒂（Lawrence Ferlinghetti）。这是一个关于旧金山作为一座岛屿的好几个世纪的古老神话。我们三面环水，随着冰川融化，水面将上升几英尺甚至一两英尺，它将淹没旧金山和旧金山半岛之间非常低洼的陆地。然后旧金山将再次成为一座岛屿。
There was always an island mentality and when I arrived in San Francisco, by ferry from Oakland having come on the train across the continent. San Francisco was like a Mediterranean city, small white buildings. No skyscrapers, just a few higher rises, maybe only 12, 14 stories. In 1950, I felt. San Francisco felt they were San Francisco's first and then only secondarily members of the United States.
这里总有一种岛屿心态，当我坐火车穿过大陆从奥克兰乘渡轮抵达旧金山时。旧金山就像一座地中海城市，白色的低矮建筑。没有摩天大楼，只有少数高层建筑，可能只有 12 层或 14 层。1950 年，我的感觉是。旧金山人觉得他们首先是旧金山人，其次才是美国人。
Alright, I think we're all here now. Welcome to our historic shoreline bicycle tour visiting the library branches in town all of them actually have pieces of the San Francisco scale wooden model built what swash behind do they the model is the main subject today in Chris Carlson and myself Lisa Ruth Elliott we direct shaping San Francisco we try to get people together in real time to talk about history how things have have changed in the city, how we can imagine our city going forward. We're gonna hug the shoreline and go along the tree. But stick together in a group, the more we can congeal as a group, the more fun we're gonna have is a ride and safer we'll all be.
好吧，我想我们现在都到齐了。欢迎来到我们的历史海岸线自行车之旅，参观城里的图书馆分馆——实际上所有分馆都有旧金山木制比例模型的碎片……模型是今天的主角，克里斯·卡尔森（Chris Carlson）和我丽莎·鲁思·埃利奥特（Lisa Ruth Elliott），我们共同领导“塑造旧金山”（Shaping San Francisco），我们试图让人们实时聚在一起讨论历史、城市是如何变化的、我们如何想象我们的城市向前发展。我们将沿着海岸线，顺着树木前行。但要作为一个群体聚在一起，我们作为一个群体越团结，我们的骑行就会越开心，我们大家也就越安全。
So that's what we learned that a long time ago on Critical Mass, density's the key. The city front. At the time of the 1938 model, San Francisco was completely oriented to the bay. The Embarcadero was known as the city front, the vast majority of people came in by ferry. And that was what you saw. That was San Francisco. The ferry building was one of the most bustling transportation hubs anywhere in the world.
这就是我们在很久以前的“关键多数”（Critical Mass）骑行活动中学到的，密度是关键。城市滨水区。在 1938 年制作模型的时候，旧金山完全是面向海湾的。内河码头（Embarcadero）被称为城市滨水区，绝大多数人都是乘渡轮进城的。这就是你所看到的。这就是旧金山。渡楼（Ferry Building）曾是世界上最繁华的交通枢纽之一。
It handled millions of people a year, and every single form of transportation, San Francisco came to it. The cable cars, street cars, trains, and omnibuses. And the whole waterfront was at the height of its working powers then. Just four years earlier, there had been the infamous Bloody Thursday and the great waterfront strike in 1934, which was a significant victory for organized labor. Open warfare rages through the streets of the city as 3,000 Union pickets, Battle 700 Police, guns, tear gas, cups and fists. Longshoremen were one of the main occupations in San Francisco. It was blue collar, it was muscular and hard drinking,
它每年接待数百万人口，旧金山的每一种交通方式都会汇聚于此。缆车、街车、火车和公共汽车。整个滨水区当时正处于其运作能力的最巅峰。就在四年前，发生了 1934 年声名狼藉的“血腥星期四”和轰轰烈烈的滨水区大罢工，这是有组织劳工的一次重大胜利。随着 3,000 名工会纠察队员与 700 名警察、枪支、催泪瓦斯、警棍和拳头搏斗，公开的战争在城市街道上肆虐。码头工人是旧金山的主要职业之一。这里是蓝领阶层，充满肌肉感且嗜酒，
and it was a whole different town. There was a great romance to it. Those finger pierces that stick out into the bay handled different types of cargos. Cobra, which is like dried coconut meat, coffee, you could smell the coffee bananas. The last block is a little bit of a climate. By the way, this building over here,
这是一个完全不同的城镇。这里有一种巨大的浪漫色彩。那些伸入海湾的手指状码头处理着不同类型的货物。椰子干（类似于干燥的椰子肉）、咖啡，你能闻到咖啡和香蕉的味道。最后一块有点像气候。顺便说一句，这边的这座建筑，
the China Basin Building, which was once upon a time a place for offloading bananas from Central America, was turned in 1974 into a food distribution center by the kidnapping of Patty Hearst. The ransom demands of the Symbianese Liberation Army was that the Hearst family give away food to poor people. And that had a big impact on San Francisco quality. The Munchucks create six for C4. Color graph hill. Cleaning the model city.
中国盆地大楼（China Basin Building），曾一度是卸载来自中美洲的香蕉的地方，1974 年因帕蒂·赫斯特（Patty Hearst）绑架案而被改造成一个食品分发中心。共生解放军（Symbionese Liberation Army）的赎金要求是赫斯特家族向穷人分发食物。这对旧金山的品质产生了巨大影响。曼查克斯创造了 6 个 C4。（注：此处原文疑为语音转写错误，保留字面意）彩色山。清理模型城市。
Where the Quake Tower is right here, they call it Signal Hill, like 38 I guess it was. So this is like Chinatown here. Jim Boyer, volunteer at Moment. I'm a commercial artist. I worked in the advertising district over there on the C4 area. We aren't doing a cleaning of downtown and tenderloin today. First of all, we start off a little brush, get the dust off a lot of dust. So that's why I'm wearing masks, because I don't know where this dust has been.
地震塔就在这里，他们称之为信号山，我想大概是 38 年吧。所以这里就像是唐人街。吉姆·博耶（Jim Boyer），现博（MOMA）志愿者。我是一名商业艺术家。我曾在那边 C4 区域的广告区工作。我们今天不清理市中心和田德隆（Tenderloin）区。首先，我们从一个小刷子开始，把灰尘刷掉，有很多灰尘。这就是为什么我戴着口罩，因为我不知道这些灰尘都在哪里待过。
50 people cleaning? Yeah. I think this cleaning process is really important. You don't only get to know the model, but there's a different relationship. So that's the model. Onview at City Hall till January 1942, when they needed the room for war purposes. The thing is that it's kind of just so huge that keeping track of all the different stories that come out of it is just, it's a lot. And where's the ferry building? and that everyone knew that that was like the end of their youth.
50 人在清理？是的。我认为这个清理过程非常重要。你不仅能了解这个模型，还会产生一种不同的关系。这就是那个模型。在市政厅展出至 1942 年 1 月，当时他们需要这个房间作军事用途。问题是它实在太巨大了，要追踪其中产生的各种故事实在是，太多了。渡楼在哪里？每个人都知道那是他们青春的结束。
The Shadow of War II was descending over the world. That was this Halcyon period that was never going to come again. The US entered the war soon after that, and there was no more going out, having frivolous days wandering around on artificial islands in the bay. San Francisco Bay became a huge arsenal wring by guns and anti-aircraft, submarine nets under the Golden Gate Bridge. It was a massive transformation of the whole way of life
第二次世界大战的阴影正笼罩着世界。那是绝不会再来的太平盛世。此后不久美国参战，再也没有人能出去，在海湾的人工岛上度过无忧无虑的闲逛日子了。旧金山湾变成了一个巨大的军火库，周围环绕着大炮和高射炮，金门大桥下布满了潜艇网。这是生活方式的巨大转变，
that happened right after this fair. Women have invaded another field, usually reserve all men. 35 women butchered started training today in San Francisco in a step to relieve the shortage caused by the departure of 1,000 male butchers for the armed services. That's the news tonight. It was like every night was Saturday night. The hours were 24 hours a day. Not only three shifts at the shipyards, but they had three shifts for the movie theaters, the restaurants, the bowling alleys.
这一切就发生在这个博览会之后不久。女性已经入侵了另一个通常由男性保留的领域。今天在旧金山，有 35 名女性屠夫开始接受培训，此举旨在缓解因 1,000 名男性屠夫参军而导致的短缺。这就是今晚的新闻。感觉就像每天都是星期六。营业时间是每天 24 小时。造船厂不仅有三班倒，电影院、餐馆、保龄球馆也有三班倒。
I mean, those boys spent money 24 hours a day until they were called back to the bases and had to shove out. My name is Tammy Takahashi. I'm a native of San Francisco. I lived my whole life here except for the four years of World War II when the Japanese American population was removed from the Pacific coast. When World War II began, there was a call out for anybody who could read and write Japanese. I volunteered. There was a makeshift, a radio station on the top floor of the palace hotel on Market Street. I was working as a translator in the office of Secret Service.
我的意思是，那些男孩们 24 小时都在花钱，直到他们被召回基地并不得不出发。我叫塔米·高桥（Tammy Takahashi）。我是旧金山市民。我一生都住在这里，除了第二次世界大战期间日裔美国人被从太平洋海岸驱逐的四年。第二次世界大战开始时，有人呼吁任何会读写日语的人站出来。我自愿参加了。在马克街（Market Street）皇宫酒店（Palace Hotel）的顶楼有一个临时广播电台。我在特勤局办公室担任翻译。
We would have these headphones on our heads translating taped radio messages from Japanese battleships on the Pacific. Full of static. Then they said, everybody, if they had a drop of Japanese blood, one-sixteenth, we were all gathered up and taken to assembly centers. The one we were locked up in is called Tampuran, a racing field, where one Kentucky thoroughbred horse was stable, five adults were put in. We lost everything. Our civil rights. We were in camp almost four years. That's a very long time to suffer deprivation and miserable food. I had to imagine things that I was fond of, an enchilada, or a tamale, some Chinese food. The Western edition.
我们头上戴着耳机，翻译来自太平洋上日本战列舰的录音无线电讯息。充满了静电。然后他们说，每个人，如果他们有一滴日本血统，百分之一十六，我们都被集合起来送到集结中心。我们被关押的地方叫做坦普兰（Tanforan），一个赛马场，一匹肯塔基纯种马住的马厩里塞进了五个成年人。我们失去了所有东西。我们的公民权利。我们在集中营里呆了将近四年。遭受剥夺和悲惨的食物是一件很长的时间。我不得不想象我喜欢的东西，玉米卷（enchilada）或玉米粉蒸肉（tamale），一些中餐。西部新区。
The Western edition in the 1920s and 30s and 40s was known as the Little United Nations that had Mexican Americans and Mexican immigrants. Filipinos had a very big Jewish component and robust Japan town centered around post. After the Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor, they were all mustard, rounded up at Jackson and Van Ness, mostly Japanese in San Francisco went to a camp called Tophaz in Utah. Right at this time comes the great African-American influx into San Francisco. Mostly from Texas, Arkansas, and Louisiana, we needed to build ships and tanks. US government sent recruiters that brought African Americans in particular to shipyard towns.
20 世纪 20、30 和 40 年代的西部新区（Western Addition）被称为“小联合国”，里面有墨西哥裔美国人和墨西哥移民。菲律宾人，有一个非常大的犹太人群体，还有一个以波斯特街（Post）为中心的繁荣日本城。在日军偷袭珍珠港之后，他们都在杰克逊街（Jackson）和范尼斯大街（Van Ness）被集中抓捕，旧金山的日本人大多去了犹他州一个叫托帕兹（Topaz）的集中营。正是在这个时候，大量非洲裔美国人涌入旧金山。主要来自得克萨斯州、阿肯色州和路易斯安那州，我们需要建造船只和坦克。美国政府派遣招聘人员，专门将非洲裔美国人带到造船厂城镇。
All of the housing that had just been vacated by the Japanese and Japanese Americans, all of that housing became available suddenly. Maya Ashley. In the early months of World War II, San Francisco's Fillmore District, all the Western Edition, experienced a visible revolution. The Yatamoto seafood market, flatly became Sam's Shushanpana and Smoke Shop. Yoshigira's hardware met a marfus into Lesolone de Bouté owned by Miss Clarenza Jackson. The Japanese shops, which sold products to Nisei customers, were taken over by Enterprising Negro businessmen and in less than a year became permanent homes away from home for the newly arrived southern blacks.
所有刚刚被日本人和日裔美国人空出来的住房，所有这些住房突然之间都空出来了。玛雅·阿什利（Maya Ashley）。第二次世界大战初期，旧金山的菲尔莫尔区（Fillmore District），整个西部新区，经历了一场肉眼可见的革命。山本海鲜市场（Yamamoto Seafood Market）干脆变成了萨姆的鞋匠铺和烟草店。吉原五金店（Yoshigira's hardware）奇迹般地变成了克伦萨·杰克逊小姐（Miss Clarenza Jackson）名下的美容沙龙。那些向日裔客户出售产品的日本商店，被有进取心的黑人商人接管，在不到一年的时间里，就成了刚到达南方的黑人们长久的“远方之家的替代”。
The Asian population blundled before my eyes. As the Japanese disappeared soundlessly and without protest, the Negroes entered with their loud jukeboxes, their just released animocities, and the relief of escape from southern bonds. The Japanese area became San Francisco's Harlem in a matter of months. During World War II, women replaced men on the street cars in San Francisco as conductors and motormen. Maya Angelou wrote, the idea of sailing up and down the hills of San Francisco in a dark
亚洲人口在我的眼前迅速减少。随着日本人在无声无息中消失，黑人们带着他们嘈杂的点唱机、刚刚释放的敌意以及逃离南方束缚的解脱感走了进来。日本区在几个月内变成了旧金山的哈莱姆区。第二次世界大战期间，女性在旧金山的电车上取代了男性，担任售票员和列车长。玛雅·安杰罗（Maya Angelou）写道：穿着深蓝色制服、腰间挂着零钱兑换器在旧金山的群山中上下行驶的想法引起了我的兴趣。她申请了这个工作，没有受到很好的接待，但她坚持了下来。
blue uniform with a money changer at my belt caught my fancy. She applied for the job, was not well received, but she persisted. I would have the job. I would be a conductor and sling a full money changer from my belt. I would. I was given blood tests, aptitude tests, physical coerity nation tests, and raw shots.
我会得到这份工作。我会成为一名列车长，腰间挂着一个满是零钱的兑换器。我会的。我接受了血液测试、能力测试、身体协调性测试和未加工的疫苗注射。然后，在一个幸福的日子里，我被雇用了，成为了旧金山街车上的第一个黑人女性。欢迎来到旧金山公共图书馆。这个模型正在激发整个城市的对话。现在还有其他三个活动正在同时举行。我们的希望是，它可以作为整个城市的隐喻，帮助我们进行更深层次的观察。我们已经进行了数百次对话，各种主题不断涌现。我敢你大概能猜到：住房、技术、有毒的士绅化、气候变化、流离失所的社区。
Then, on a blissful day, I was hired as the first Negro on the San Francisco Street Talks. Welcome to the San Francisco Public Library. The model is inspiring conversations all over the city. There's three other events happening right now. Our hope is that it can serve as a metaphor for the city at large to help us take a deeper look. We have had hundreds of conversations with themes came up over and over again. I'm sure you could probably guess housing, technology, toxic gentrification, climate change, displaced community.
你好，我是杰雷尔·菲利普斯（Jarelle Phillips），旧金山本地人，在菲尔莫尔土生土长。当那场大迁徙发生时，我的祖父母都是从南方来到这里的。我通过城市中的几种方式进行表演或教学。我一直在做一个名为“我是旧金山：黑人的过去与现在”（I Am San Francisco Black Past in the Presence）的项目。非洲 diaspora（海外流散）及其影响和冲击。在旧金山长大，我在一个非常黑人的世界里长大，这可能很难想象。在一个我上过全黑人私立学校、主要是黑人教堂的城市，我经常去湾景猎人角（Bayview Hunters Point）。
Hello, I'm Jarelle Phillips, San Francisco native, born and raised in the field more. My grandparents all came here from the south when that migration was happening. I perform my teach a couple of ways throughout the city. I've been doing a project called I Am San Francisco Black Pass in the Presence. The African diaspora and its influence and impact. Growing up in San Francisco, I grew up in a very black world, which is probably hard to even imagine. In a city that I went to all black private school, predominantly black church, and I went to Bayview Hunters Point a lot.
所以我一直在两个非常著名的黑人社区之间穿梭。我们，特别是非洲裔美国人，在某种程度上一直在流浪，从一个地方到另一个地方，试图长期建立家园和社区。作为一个民族，我们搬出了南方，我们来到了这里。詹姆斯·鲍德温（James Baldwin）说过，我们尽可能地向西走。现在我们到了这样一个地步：非洲裔美国人一直在回去，
So I was bouncing between two very well-known black neighborhoods. We, African-Americans specifically have been, in some ways, wandering and going from place to place trying to create home and community for a long time now. As a people, we moved out of the South, and we came over here. James Baldwin said, we came as far west as we could go. Now we're at a point where African Americans have been going back,
像回旋镖一样回到南方，并进一步分散到莫德斯托（Modesto）等地，我们 17 岁时搬出了城市。我不想，但我不得不。一年后，只要我一到法定年龄，我就回来了。但我的父母每天都回到城里。我奶奶的房子仍然是大家的信件寄到的地方。
like Boomerang going back to the South, and dispersing further out into places like Modesto, and we moved out of the city when I was 17. I didn't want to, I had to. I came back a year later as soon as I was old enough. But my parents come back into the city every day. My grandma's house is still the house that everybody's mail goes to.
对许多家庭来说，他们的社区中心——无论是教堂还是什么空间——仍然是人们在周末及其他时间聚集的地方。我觉得这种联系依然存在。我们必须非常小心。在我看来，菲尔莫尔区的士绅化和变化可能会在任何地方发生，因为我亲眼目睹了这种变化。战争结束后，当造船厂的工作岗位枯竭时，
For a lot of families, their community center, whether it's the church or whatever space site is, is still where people come to on the weekends and whatnot. I feel like that connection is still there. We have to be very mindful. The gentrification of the change that happened and the film work can happen as far as I'm concerned anywhere because I saw that change. After the war ended, when the shipyard jobs dried up,
这大群人突然失业了。面对工会招聘做法中的种族歧视，他们找不到其他类型的工作。西部新区，住房存量真的非常破旧。我的意思是，在城市元老的眼中，它被视为一个日渐衰败的社区。他们想出了这个计划来重建整个西部新区。他们最终砸毁了成百上千栋房屋，数百家由黑人拥有的企业。
this large group of people were suddenly unemployed. Facing racism in the hiring practices of unions and couldn't get other kinds of jobs. Western Edition, the housing stock is really run down. I mean, the eyes of city fathers, it's seen as a blighted neighborhood. They came up with this plan to redevelop the whole Western Edition. They ended up smashing down the Korean houses, hundreds of black owned businesses.
这是 60 世纪和 70 年代城市规划史上一个非常黑暗的时期。为了规划社区和高层开发项目，整个街区被拆毁。日本城和菲尔莫尔发生的事情就是其中的一个完美例子。我是爱莉森·阿里亚夫（Allison Ariaf）。我是城市规划
This is a very dark period of urban planning history in the 60s and 70s. Whole neighborhoods were demolished in favor of planned communities and high-rise developments. What happened in Japan town in Filmora's a perfect example of that. My name is Allison Ariaf. I'm the editorial director of the Urban Planning
与政策智库“斯普尔”（Spur）的社论总监。这带来的实际效果是，坦率地说，它把人们塞进了一些非常糟糕的建筑里，摧毁了当地的企业，抹去了住在那里的人们的联系，这种方式，我认为人们还没有真正走出来。而且我认为这对城市规划也非常具有破坏性。某些社区将永远不会信任这个过程。
and Policy Think Tank Spur. What that had the effect of doing is it put people in, frankly, some really bad architecture, destroyed local businesses, erased the connections for the people who lived there in a way that, I don't think people have really gotten over. And I think it was also really damaging to urban planning. Certain communities will never have trust in the process.
我认为我们正处于弄清楚如何在建造新建筑、新街区和新社区时最好地让社区参与、尊重和告知社区的关键时刻。我认为我们在思考这些问题的方 式上有一个巨大的范式转变，但它来得很慢。中国城和北滩（North Beach）共用模型的一部分。现在它在北滩，这很棒，因为它是一座额外的小山。我们不必爬山。图书馆。
I think we're at a really crucial moment of figuring out how best to involve respect and inform communities as new buildings and neighborhoods and communities are being built. I think that there's a big paradigm shift in the way that we think about these issues, but it's slow and coming. China's Hound and North Beach are sharing a piece of the model. Right now it's at North Beach, which is great because it's an extra hill. We don't have to climb. The libraries.
旧金山有着悠久的图书馆历史。随着淘金热的蓬勃发展，第一座图书馆于 1852 年在一家男子禁酒旅馆的一个房间里开业。1877 年，在安德鲁·S·哈利戴（Andrew S. Halliday）的带头下，建立了一个面向所有人的免费图书馆，他还发明了缆车。从一开始，图书馆的成功就令人惊叹，今天依然如此，它在全市拥有 29 个分馆，
San Francisco has a very long history with libraries. As the gold rush boomed, the first library opened in 1852 in a room in a men's temperance hotel. In 1877, a free library for all was established, spearheaded by Andrew S. Halliday, who also invented the cable car. From the start, the library's success was astounding, and it remained so today, with its 29 branches
模型的 29 个对应的街区部分就在那里展出。所以这些都可以被拿出来，这样我们就可以看到我们抹去的街道。是的，我习惯在谷歌地图上看到这个，但以 3D 形式看到它，说明你真的对比例有了概念。哦，我的房子在那里。你的房子在那里。当他们制作这个模型时，他们派人去查看每栋房子的颜色。所以你的房子的颜色
throughout the city, where 29 corresponding neighborhood sections of the model were put on display. So each one of these can be lifted out, so that we can see the street that we've wiped out. Yes, I'm used to seeing this in Google Maps, but seeing it 3D is saying you really got a sense of the scale. Oh my house is there. Your house is there. When they had it made, they sent people out to look at the color of every house. So the color of your house
在这里就是它原本的颜色。实际上我们在写作时提出的问题之一是制作这个模型的意义何在。有些碎片被用于这些规划练习，在 20 世纪 70 年代“市场以南”（South of Market）进行重建时，随着大型建筑的阴影落下，他们开始拆除酒店、理发店和咖啡馆，并建立莫斯康尼中心（Moscone Center）和旧金山现代艺术博物馆等设施。他们开始摆弄各种可能性。
here is the color it was. One of the questions actually is we were writing was what was the point of making this model. Some pieces were used for these planning exercises where the shadows would fall for larger buildings as redevelopment happened in South of Market in the 1970s and they started raising the hotels, barber shops and cafes and put in things like the Moscone Center and San Francisco Museum of Modern Art. They started playing around with what's possible.
当我们发现它时，问题之一是：旧金山还有旧金山的空间吗？在博物馆里，我们试图找到一个地方把它们全部放下，但我意识到它太大了。所以我们与图书馆合作，尽可能多地将碎片放进分馆，最终这大约是 140 个碎片中的 70 个。我们这里有什么？
One of the questions when we found it was, is there room for San Francisco and San Francisco? At the museum, we tried to find a place to put it all, but I realized it's so large. So we worked with the library to get as many pieces as we could into the branches, and that ended up being about 70 of the 140 pieces. What do we have here?
GPA。那是格伦公园（Glen Park）。是的，格伦公园这里有这两块碎片。格伦公园高速公路起义。我们带着 13 岁的女儿去格伦公园图书馆看这个模型，它位于我们所谓的市中心中间，我住在一个大山坡上。我下面的所有东西都是奶酪农场，有很多地震棚。曾有一位开发商想在格伦公园建一个动物园，
GPA. That's Glen Park. Yeah, Glen Park has these two pieces here. The Glen Park Freeway Revolt. We took my 13 year old daughter to go look at the model at the Glen Park Library, which is in the middle of our little quote unquote downtown, where I live on a big hill. Everything above me was dairy farms and there were lots of earthquake shacks. There was a developer who wanted to build a zoo
以此吸引人们在社区买房。1948 年，加州公路局决定用高速公路纵横交错这座城市。而一群母亲和家庭主妇阻止了这一切的发生。格伦公园户外艺术联盟和旧金山妇女俱乐部成功阻止了这项高速公路工程。格伦公园高速公路起义。女性和妈妈们实际上在湾区领导了相当多的此类起义，
in Glen Park. As a way to attract people to buy homes in the neighborhood. In 1948, the California Highway Department decided they wanted to crisscross the city with freeways. And a bunch of moms and housewives stopped that from happening. The Glen Park outdoor art league and the San Francisco women's club managed to stop this freeway effort. Glen Park freeway revolt. Women and moms have actually led quite a number of revolts like this around
包括帮助推翻一项非常奇怪的填海造湾计划——“拯救海湾”运动，在这场运动中，这三位女性挑战了企业、富有的土地所有者、政客，并扭转了“你应该填海造湾以进行更多开发”的想法。我很高兴看到这个模型今天回归，因为它呈现了一段非常迷人的历史——有时是积极的，很多时候是消极的——关于这座城市是如何成长和发展的。西部新区图书馆分馆。很多人来看这个模型。
the Bay area including helping to overturn a really bizarre plan to pave over the Bay, the save the Bay movement where this trio of women challenged companies, wealthy landowners, politicians, and reverse this idea that you should pave over the Bay to do more development. I'm so glad to see this model come back today because it presents a really fascinating history, sometimes positive, lots of times negative of how this city has grown and developed. The Western Edition branch. A lot of people came to see the model.
你会注意到一条穿过的大红线。那些永远不会互相交谈的人突然开始谈论红线划定（Redlining），人们试图弄清楚为什么这里有一条大红线，人们说因为那是红线划定，不，但到底是什么，因为那是红线划定？红线划定基本上划定了有色人种的居住区。这是地图上的种族隔离。我叫内玛·迪恩（Naima Dean），我是旧金山公共图书馆系统西部新区图书馆分馆的馆长。我爸爸在这个街区有一个爵士乐俱乐部，在 60 年代和 70 年代，同时比尔·格雷厄姆（Bill Graham）在菲尔莫尔做他的事情。
You'll notice a big red line going through. People who would never have a conversation with one another suddenly just talk about the red lining and people trying to figure out why is there a big red line here and people saying because that's red lining and no, but like what is it because it's red lining? The red lining basically delineated where people of color would live. It's segregation on a map. My name is Naima Dean and I am the manager of the Western Edition Branch Library of San Francisco Public Library System. My dad had a jazz club in this neighborhood in the 60s and 70s at the same time as Bill
他们一起做了很多项目。大妈妈索顿（Big Mama Thornton）、乔治·杜克（George Duke）、鲍比·哈钦森（Bobby Hutchison）、迈尔斯·戴维斯（Miles Davis）。我在这个街区长大，在 80 年代这里全都是非洲裔美国人。尽管如此，这就是菲尔莫尔，这就是菲尔莫尔，现在这里是阿拉莫广场（Alamo Square）、海斯谷（Hayes Valley）、诺帕（Nopa）、罗迪（Lodi）以及所有这些昵称。我的意思是，它们是房地产的名字，是销售的名字。我们制作了一张地图来配合这个项目。人们可以在便签纸上写下回忆，有人说，我的日裔美国人家庭经常来西部新区图书馆。我丈夫用日语借阅了山本周五郎的小说。
Graham doing his stuff at the film more. And they did a lot of projects together. Big Mama Thornton, George Duke, Bobby Hutchison, Miles Davis. I grew up in this neighborhood, and it was all African-American in the 80s. Still, this was the mo, this was the film mo, and now it's Alamo Square and Hayes Valley and Nopa and Lodi and all these nicknames. I mean, they're real estate names, they're sale names. We had made a map to accompany the project. People could write a memory on a post-it and someone said, my Japanese American family came
次数太多了，图书馆最后把这些书送给了他。太棒了。哦，我喜欢这个。哈维·米尔克（Harvey Milk）的宽镜头相机店。我记得我爸爸告诉我，他当时真的很喜欢哈维·米尔克，因为哈维·米尔克愿意融合而不是隔离。他努力工作，因为西部新区与卡斯特罗区（Castro）相邻。让我们看看我们在西部新区能找到什么。我住在一栋大楼里。我住在菲尔莫尔。我爱我的莫。
often to the Western Edition Library. My husband checked out the novels of Yamamoto Shiguro in Japanese. So many times that the library eventually gave these to him. That's great. Oh, I like this one. Harvey Milk's wide lens camera store. I remember my dad telling me that like he really liked Harvey Milk at the time because Harvey Milk was willing to integrate and not segregate. He worked hard because the Western edition is adjacent to the Castro. Let's see what we can find right in the Western edition. I live in a big building. I live in the film O. I love my Mo.
六月虫（June Bug）和纳亚（Naya），2019 年。机械街 1133 号。红支行之夜是爱尔兰人交往的地方，它不是一个高级大厅，它只是，它就是最棒的。当他们每周六晚上跳舞时，我们在那里遇到了所有的爱尔兰人。我们有来自奥克兰的强尼·哈拉汉（Johnny Hallahan）和他的优秀大乐队。我们跳了一整夜。
June Bug and Naya, 2019. 1133 machine street. The night of the red branch was a place where the Irish mesh, it wasn't a fancy hall, it was just, it it was the greatest. And when they were every Saturday night dancing, we met all the Irish there. And we had Johnny Hallahan from Oakland, nice big band. And we dance all night. From further dark until five o'clock in the morning, we go to Mrs. Pickett's house.
从天黑一直到早上五点，我们去皮克特太太（Mrs. Pickett）家。她是爱尔兰人，我记得她丈夫是一名警察。他去睡觉了，而她整夜陪着我们。她太好了。她过去常常把地下室借给我们这些年轻的爱尔兰人。五点钟我们坐公共汽车去圣伊gnatius（St. Ignatius），我们必须去做弥撒，回家睡三四个小时，然后去打爱尔兰足球。如果你向右看，你会看到爱尔兰山的最后一个小树桩还在那里。曾经在特里奥山（Trio Hill）有一个第三个山峰叫做爱尔兰山，整个空域都被填满了，我们即将从那里疾驰而下。
She was Irish, her husband was a police officer, I believe. He got to bed and she stayed up with us all night long. She was so sweet. She used to give her her basement for us young Irish people. Five o'clock we take a bus and we go up to St. Ignatius, we had to get to Mass, come home and go to bed for three or four hours and then actually be jelly to the Irish football. If you just look to your right you'll see the last little stump of Irish Hill still there. Once upon a time there was a third peak at the Treo Hill called Irish Hill which was all filled up this entire airspace we're about to go hurtling down through.
有 98 级台阶才能到达顶部。山峦。在早期，有钱人不住在山上。它们完全无法接近。你甚至无法让一匹马爬上去。要么覆满沙丘和灌木丛。但在缆车出现后，它开发了诺布山（Nob Hill）。突然之间，诺布山成了有钱人居住的地方。
Had 98 steps to get in the top of it. The hills. In the early days, rich people didn't live on the hills. They were completely inaccessible. You couldn't even get a horse to go up them. Either cover with sand dunes and scrub brush. But after the cable car, that opened up knob hill. And all of a sudden knob hill became where the rich people lived.
诺布山、电报山突然之间，诺布山成了有钱人居住的地方。诺布山、电报山、俄罗斯山，这些市中心的主要山脉，几十年来阻碍了城市的扩张。这就是为什么在旧金山一直到 20 世纪初，人们对填平他们能填平的每一滴水有着一种狂热的原因之一。现在的金融区。那全都在水下。那是用废弃的沉船填平的。
Nob, telegraph of a sudden Nob Hill became where the rich people lived. Nob telegraph Russian, the main downtown hills, prevented the expansion of the city for decades. That was one of the reasons that there was this mania that went on in San Francisco and tell the early 20th century for filling in every single bit of water that they could fill in. What is now the financial district? That was all underwater. That was filled in using ships, scuttled. There's sunken ships that formed part of the bay bottom
有沉船构成了金融区海湾底部的一部分。作为一名地理学家，我感兴趣的是，这些建筑是在 1906 年地震和火灾之后建造的，以取代被夷为平地的建筑，但它们建在从淘金热遗留下来相同的产权线上，根本不考虑不应该在其上建造的山丘和湿地，因为它们会遭遇地震。西蒙娜·德·波伏娃（Simone de Beauvoir）访问旧金山时曾评论说，这座城市看起来像是由一个以前从未到过这里的人规划的。
in the financial district. What interests me as a geographer is these buildings were built after the 1906 earthquake and fire to replace buildings that were leveled, but they're built on the same property lines that were left over from the gold rush with no regard for the hills and the wetlands which it shouldn't have been built on because they look for an earthquake. Simone de Beauvoir when she visited San Francisco remarked that it looked like the city had been laid out by somebody who would never been here before.
就像这座城市是由一个以前从未到过这里的人规划的一样。我们要一直往下走，直到到达海滩街。水上公园（Aquatic Park）。由于大量采矿残渣覆盖了海湾底部，今天的海湾要浅得多。我们冲走了相当于六条巴拿马运河数量的残渣，才把黄金从加利福尼亚的山丘和山脉中冲刷到水道和海湾中，而且它充满了甲基汞。所以，除非它们是像鲱鱼那样停留时间很短的访客，否则不要吃海湾里的鱼。鲱鱼是安全的。
like the city had been laid out by somebody who had never been here before. We're going to head down until we get to beach streets. Aquatic Park. The Bay is much shallower today because of how much mining debris coating the bottom of the Bay. We had washed away the equivalent of six Panama canals worth of debris to get the gold out of the hills and mountains of California into the waterways and into the bay And it's full of methyl mercury So if don't eat fish out of the bay unless they're very short-term visitors like herring her safe
条纹鲈鱼则不然。渔夫的工作。刚刚路过水上公园，刚刚路过水上公园和所有的的高桅横帆船。右边那栋巨大的蓝白相间建筑，海豚俱乐部（Dolphin Club）。我系好领带了吗？我的领带。你可能会开始外出。你知道我的意思吗？
Stripe bass or not Fishman's work Just passing the aquatic park just passing the aquatic park and all the tall ships. Big blue and white building to my right, the dolphin club. I get the flock tied, right? My tie. You might start going out on you. You know what I mean?
可能会。而且最重要的一件事，关于在这东西里游泳。看着任何眼睛然后走。你不需要在所有的垃圾里游泳。它刚刚到这里。我的名字是卢姆·马塞利（Lume Marselli）。这个俱乐部正如他所说，建于 1887 年。这是一个游泳和赛艇俱乐部。
Might. And number one thing, about swimming in this stuff. Look at any eye and go. You don't have to swim in all the trash. It's just got up to here. My name is Lume Marselli. This club is what he says, 1887. And it's a swimming and boarding club.
我们全年都在海湾里游泳。我们知道穿什么。我 12 或 13 岁时开始捕鱼。卢姆·马塞利。胶水卢（Lue the glue）。他有点像海豚俱乐部的守护者。他住在那里一个小阁楼里。他是海豚俱乐部的守护者之一，住在那里一个小阁楼里。他是北滩的老牌居民之一。在海豚俱乐部，有很多老派意大利人，
We swim in a bay all year round. We know what suits. I started a fish when I was 12 or 13 years old. Lume Marselli. Lue the glue. He's sort of the custodian of the dolphin club. And he lives in a little attic there. And he's one of the custodian of the dolphin club and he lives in a little attic there. And he's one of the old stoves of North Beach. At the dolphin club there are a lot of old Italian men,
我们在海湾里游一整年。我们知道什么合适。我十二三岁的时候开始钓鱼。卢姆·马塞利。胶水卢。他可以说是海豚俱乐部的守护人。他住在那里一个小阁楼里。他是海豚俱乐部的守护人之一，住在那里一个小阁楼里。他是北滩的老居民之一。在海豚俱乐部有很多老意大利人，
like firemen, policemen, and waiters, and exercise a little swim a little. And then they cook for each other. And they have a lot of wine. they just sit around and talk about the old days and talk about sex and what's going to happen to somebody if he has testicular cancer. And you've got to give him a certain kind of liver. And they have all these theories based on what their mothers told them. And they cook food for each other. And I think it really keeps them going. It's really a problem for old people because where can they cook if they're relegated to smaller and smaller spaces and then they're given terrible food and I wonder they die. North Beach. The area known as North Beach was once an actual beach. It was filled in around the late 19th century and warehouses, fishing roars and docks were built on the newly formed
就像消防员、警察和侍者一样，他们做做运动，游一会儿泳。然后他们互相做饭。喝很多酒。他们就坐在那儿聊聊过去的日子，聊聊性，聊聊如果有人得了睾丸癌会怎么样。你还得给他换个特定类型的肝脏。他们有各种各样的理论，都是他们母亲告诉他们的。他们互相做饭。我觉得这真的能让他们坚持下去。对老年人来说这真是一个问题，因为如果他们只能住在越来越小的空间里，吃着糟糕的食物，他们还能去哪里做饭呢，难怪他们会死。北滩。被称为北滩的这个地区曾经真的是一片海滩。它大约在19世纪后期被填平，仓库、渔桟和码头就在新形成的
shoreline. This is the piece of the model that has quite tower on it and St. Peter and Paul's church. Here's Peggy Nicarbacher at Porchlight. I'm Peggy Nicarbacher, I'm a native saffron ciscan for three generations. I grew up over on Pacific Avenue, but at about eight or nine, I had an aunt, eat a baronio, and she'd bring me over on the bus to North Beach. We'd come for pickled pigs feet, basil, no stores had anything like that in those days,
海岸线上建起来。这是模型上有高塔以及圣彼得和圣保罗教堂的那部分。这里是 Porchlight 的佩吉·尼卡巴克。我是佩吉·尼卡巴克，我是三代土生土长的旧金山人。我在太平洋大道那边长大，但大概八九岁的时候，我有个阿姨叫伊塔·巴罗尼奥，她会带我坐公交车去北滩。我们会去吃腌猪脚、罗勒，当年没有哪家商店有这些东西，
and we'd have a date with some of her older friends. They'd have little cotton house dresses on with their nylons kind of rolled down, and they'd come out in their house shoes. And I knew there was something happening here. And the day that we left, we were waiting for the bus. It looked like there was blood coming down, Fulbert Street. And it was a garage wine making set up of, you know, some old Italian guys. And then when I was in high school, I'd come over with my
我们还会跟她的一些老朋友约会。她们穿着小棉布家居裙，尼龙袜有点往下退，穿着拖鞋就出来了。我知道这里有些事情正在发生。我们离开那天，正在等公交车。富尔伯特街上看起来好像有血流下来。那是几个老意大利人搞的车库酿酒作坊。后来我上高中时，会和我的
two best friends. Weed where our mothers, print coats, put on black tights, and we'd set in cafes and read poetry, and think we were beatnets, little shiny face beatnets. And then I came when I was in college, and we went to see Carol Dota and to the jazz workshop. And we hung out at a bar called Mooney's. I wish pop up on Grand Avenue. The barkeeper was Sean Mooney and he never ate.
两个最好朋友一起过来。我们穿着妈妈的印花大衣，套上黑色紧身裤，坐在咖啡馆里读诗，自认为是垮掉派，闪亮着脸蛋的垮掉派。后来我上大学时也来过，我们去看卡罗尔·多塔，去爵士工坊。我们在一个叫穆尼的酒吧闲逛。我希望它能出现在格兰大道的爆米花机上。酒保叫肖恩·穆尼，他从不吃东西。
And we'd come and we'd bring him sandwiches. He said, well, if you guys want to feed me so much, why don't you take over the kitchen? So we decided we'd start the next day. And we had leotards on no-bodies, two or three skirts, lots of necklaces. We had no idea of what we were doing. We went down to the butcher, Miss Bruno Yackepie, who was half a block away and said,
我们会来给他带三明治。他说，好吧，如果你们这么想喂饱我，为什么不干脆接管厨房呢？于是我们决定第二天就开业。我们穿着紧身衣裤、连体衣、两三条裙子，戴着好多项链。我们根本不知道自己在干什么。我们走到离这半个街区远、由布鲁诺·亚克皮先生经营的肉铺说，
we've run out of everything, and it was about 11 o'clock, and we were open till two. We need help. What are we gonna do? He said, we'll always have sausages, make Portuguese beans stew. The bakery was right next door,
我们什么都卖完了，当时大概11点，我们营业到2点。我们需要帮助。我们该怎么办？他说，我们总会有香肠，做个葡萄牙豆焖肉吧。面包店就在隔壁，
get nice hot bread. As a matter of fact, go over to the bakery and get a roll. And he'd cut some telemaid cheese that had a special taste because it was May. The cows had been eating some special clover. And he'd hold, he was huge, and he had blood all over his apron. And he'd hold a sandwich to his ample breast. And by the time you got it, it was a grilled cheese sandwich.
拿些热乎的好面包。事实上，去面包店拿个卷。他还会切一些特梅拉德奶酪，因为正是五月，所以有一种特殊的风味。奶牛一直在吃某种特殊的苜蓿。他会抱——他长得人高马大，围裙上溅满了血。他把三明治贴在他宽阔的胸前。等你拿到手时，它就变成了一个烤奶酪三明治。
LAUGHTER MUSIC We continue the Kitchen Sisters' tour of San Francisco through the WPA Model City. After this. We rejoin the Kitchen sisters in North Beach. The olive tree, that's what we need. Peas and poe tree.
笑声 音乐 我们继续“厨房姐妹”通过 WPA 模型城市对旧金山的游览。稍后继续。我们重新加入北滩的“厨房姐妹”。橄榄树，这就是我们需要的。豌豆和诗意。
Having an olive tree? I mean, it's a symbol of life. Good morning and thank you for coming out here today on this beautiful Monday morning. My name is Carla Short on the superintendent of the Bureau of Urban Forestry in San Francisco. For the last 15 years we have honored people with a signature tree. Ruth Asawa was an honoree. Montgomery, Mathai, Nelson Mandela, Cesar Chavez, Irene Precios, and activists in the Portola District.
拥有一棵橄榄树？我的意思是，它是生命的象征。大家早上好，谢谢大家今天在这个美丽的周一早晨来到这里。我是卡拉·肖特，旧金山城市林业局局长。在过去的15年中，我们用标志性的树木来向人们致敬。露丝·阿萨瓦就是受表彰者之一。蒙哥马利、马太、纳尔逊·曼德拉、凯撒·查韦斯、艾琳·普雷西奥斯，还有波托拉区的活动人士。
We are in Norse Beach neighborhood, not far from City Lights bookstore. This neighborhood would not look like this neighborhood at the Lawrence Firling Deadby not actively championed as thriving writers and artists community. The bookstore was always in the same location, 261 Columbus Avenue. We had this anarchist slant right from the beginning, and at that time North Beach was populated by, well, like, 90 percent Italians. Some of the first publications we sold were two Italian anarchist newspapers in Italian, and among the people who would buy the
我们位于北滩社区，离城市之光书店不远。如果没有劳伦斯·费尔林格蒂积极倡导将其打造成一个欣欣向荣的作家和艺术家社区，这个社区绝不会是现在的样子。书店一直都在同一个地方，哥伦布大道261号。我们从一开始就带有这种无政府主义的倾向，当时北滩的人口结构是，嗯，大约百分之九十都是意大利人。我们出售的第一批出版物之一就是两份用意大利语编写的意大利无政府主义报纸，而购买这些
newspaper were the scavengers on the garbage truck. I remember one guy wearing a derby and baggy pants would rush in off the garbage truck and get his copy of you man of the Nova or a Ladunat that was the other one. My father bought a little house. We lived in an alley called Winterplace, in North Beach, one of the first Chinese families living in that neighborhood in the 50s. And it was all little Sicily,
报纸的人中就包括垃圾车上的清道夫。我记得有个家伙戴着圆顶礼帽，穿着宽松的裤子，从垃圾车上急匆匆地跑下来，买他那一本《人类新报》或者《劳动报》，那是另一份报纸。我父亲买了一座小房子。我们住在北滩一条叫温特普莱斯的巷子里，那是50年代住在该社区的第一批中国家庭之一。这里全都是小西西里，
the smell of coffee, the bread, ravioli, fat tree, powered Mason Street car runs down, could hear it every day. I would listen to it like my music box, the fog horns and the cable cars. Then I would secure and I could go to sleep. I'm Jenny Lim, poet, playwright.
咖啡的香味、面包、意大利饺子、肥树，梅森街的有轨电车轰鸣着驶过，每天都能听到。我听着它，就像听我的音乐盒一样，还有雾笛和缆车。然后我就能安心入睡了。我是珍妮·林，诗人、剧作家。
My father was a working class immigrant. Took on jobs, working at the Fairmont Hotel as a janitor and then became a bus boy. My mother was a sewing woman and worked all day and all night at a sewing machine. We children, there were seven of us, and we were just on the loose, running the streets, Chinatown and North Beach.
我父亲是一个工人阶级移民。做过各种工作，在费尔蒙酒店当过门房，后来成了服务生。我母亲是个缝纫女工，日夜不停地在缝纫机前工作。我们这些孩子有七个，我们就像脱缰野马一样，在唐人街和北滩的街道上到处跑。
Chinatown. This is Herb Canes from San Francisco, the magic city that's a sight to behold. We're walking down the narrow, shop line, main street of San Francisco's Chinatown. We call it Grand Avenue, but to the Chinese it's still Dupont Guy. A block away is Port Smith Square. The scene of a San Francisco tradition, the Chinese Goon Festival. The Chinese were not allowed to live west of power until as late as the 40s or 50s.
唐人街。这是旧金山的赫布·凯恩，这座魔幻的城市真是一处美景。我们正走在旧金山唐人街狭窄、商店林立的主街上。我们叫它格兰大道，但对中国人来说，它依然是杜邦街。一个街区之外是朴次茅斯广场。旧金山传统的举办地——旧金山华埠中秋节。直到40年代或50年代，中国人都被禁止住在电力线以西。
Those covenants, it's incredible how long they remained on the books. My mother sang wooden fish songs, the Ichineret, folk songs of the peasants, and I remember the old folks singing these songs in Chinatown. This one is when that my mother sang whenever she mended our clothes, whenever there's a hole in a piece of cloth that's at Portalfour, negative spirits to enter. Before the earthquake, Chinatown looked more like the rest of San Francisco, mostly western-style architecture. After the earthquake, in response to this concerted movement on the part of the White Estals,
这些契约，它们在法案里保留了那么久真是令人难以置信。我母亲唱木鱼歌，伊奇内雷特，农民的民歌，我记得老人们在唐人街唱这些歌。这首歌是我母亲每当给我们补衣服时都会唱的，每当一块布上有个洞，那就是波特福，会让邪灵进入。地震发生前，唐人街看起来更像旧金山的其他地方，大多是西式建筑。地震发生后，为了应对白人上流社会的协调一致的运动，
to move Chinatown out of downtown San Francisco, down to Hunter's Point, the Chinese managed to start rebuilding right away. Chinese merchants working with white architects came up with an idea where they would take elements of traditional Chinese architecture, goadahs and corbels, rot iron, those all have structural function. In Chinatown, they're just tacked on to conventional buildings to make it look wild and exotic and Chinese and enticing. They put a lot of neon and a lot of electric lights, so it became this kind of fairyland environment, and that was very successful.
他们试图将唐人街从旧金山市中心搬迁到亨特角，华人却设法立即开始重建。华人商贩与白人建筑师合作，想出了一个主意，他们采用传统中国建筑的元素，牌坊和牛腿、熟铁，这些都有结构功能。在唐人街，它们只是贴在常规建筑上，使其看起来狂野、异国情调、中国风且引人入胜。他们安装了大量的霓虹灯和许多电灯，于是这里变成了一种童话般的仙境环境，而且非常成功。
We hired a marching band funeral procession for my father, Adam March, from the mortuary to winter place. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. We go back to the original grass roots at the first marching band in Chinatown. My name is Clifford, last name is Yee, people come out to look to see if they know the person.
我们为我父亲雇了一支葬礼仪仗队，从殡仪馆游行到温特普莱斯。晚安。晚安。晚安。晚安。我们回到了唐人街第一支仪仗队的原始草根发源地。我名字叫克利福德，姓余，人们出来看看他们是否认识这个人。
Many people out of respect will bow, people will take their cats off, because out of being respected to a leader of the disease. My name is John Copolo, I'm with the Green Street March worry man. Come down claim and make a left on grant. This is where we do our heavy things you know. It's the biggest audience. So what we do is we slow down like going to this one particular dirge march. St. Jude funeral march. Orange, Firling, Getty, at City Light's bookstore. Green Street, Marchberry, Marching Man just passed by. The back door of City Light's is in Chinatown. The front door is in the Western world. Green Street, Marchway, Marching Man marches right down Green Street and turns into Columbus
出于敬意，许多人会鞠躬，人们会脱下帽子，因为这是对逝去领袖的尊重。我是约翰·科普洛，我和绿街仪仗队的人在一起。下来到克莱因街，在格兰街左转。这是我们做重头戏的地方，你知道的。这是最大的观众群体。所以我们要做的是放慢速度，就像走向这个特定的哀乐游行一样。圣犹大葬礼进行曲。奥兰治、费尔林格蒂，在城市之光书店。绿街仪仗队的仪仗队员刚刚走过。城市之光的后门在唐人街。前门在西方世界。绿街仪仗队的仪仗队员顺着绿街直行，转入哥伦布
Avenue where all the cafe sitters at the sidewalk cafe tables sit talking and laughing and looking right through it as if it happened every day in little old wooden North Beach San Francisco. But at the same time, feeling thrilled by the stirring sound of the gallant marching band, as if it were celebrating life and never heard of death. We're going to use the model today as a catalyst for a conversation around the controversial topic of the impact of tech capital on the city of San Francisco. We'll open with a panelist and this hyper growth of tech has brought with it both extraordinary wealth and an influx of people. This boom is phenomenal. There's a most prosperous place in the world in this decade.
大道，所有坐在路边咖啡馆桌旁的咖啡客们都在那里谈笑风生，目不斜视地看着它走过，仿佛这在旧金山小小的老木质北滩是每天都在发生的事一样。但与此同时，又被这英勇的仪仗队激昂的乐声所震撼，仿佛它是在庆祝生命，从未听说过死亡。今天，我们将把这个模型作为催化剂，围绕科技资本对旧金山市影响这一充满争议的话题展开对话。我们将由一位小组成员开场，科技的这种超高速增长带来了非凡的财富和大量的人口涌入。这场繁荣真是惊人。这是这十年中世界上最繁荣的地方。
This prosperity has also led to growing inequality, gentrification, demographic changes. More billionaires per square year. And some would say a really unsustainable and unhealthy impact on housing cost, infrastructure, and the environment. One thing that we need to do is break up some of these big companies.
这种繁荣也导致了日益加剧的不平等、中产阶级化、人口结构的变化。每平方公里亿万富翁最多。有些人会说，这对住房成本、基础设施和环境产生了真正不可持续且不健康的影響。我们需要做的一件事是拆分其中一些大公司。
It's always much higher. When did we have mass housing for the working people? After World War II, the collapse of the 20s plus the taxes of the New Deal plus we've got to have this conversation at a national level about income inequality and about a living wage about guaranteed national housing. One more question, I guess the general in the back of the glasses. If you want to talk of the homeless prompt for a second, the reason isn't because of tech lords
总是要高得多。我们什么时候有过面向劳动人民的大规模保障性住房？二战后，20世纪20年代的崩溃加上新政的税收，我们必须在国家层面上就收入不平等、生活工资以及国家保障住房展开这场对话。还有一个问题，我想是后面戴眼镜的那位。如果你想谈一会儿无家可归的问题，原因不是因为科技巨头
and stem lords who are destroying the city. It's because old people who moved here in 1975 never wanted to build a single house. You can't build a homeless shelter, you can't do anything, and you're wondering, oh, I'm gonna blame the newcomers, but really maybe just kind of basically agree with you. I wouldn't think they're probably, oh, I'm gonna blame the newcomers, but really maybe just I Basically agree with you and that we need well, I don't right. We're talking about class and race
和理工科巨头正在摧毁这座城市。是因为1975年搬到这里的老年人们从来不想建造哪怕一栋房子。你不能建收容所，你什么也做不了，而你却在想，哦，我要怪新来的人，但实际上可能只是基本上同意你的看法。我不认为它们可能，哦，我要怪新来的人，但实际上可能只是我基本上同意你的看法，我们需要，好吧，我不对。我们在谈论阶级和种族
As a fellow young person Take one step further and like look at the reasons. I'm going to put another half a billion dollars into immediate funding for navigation centers. So we need to work together as a whole. This is a rapid rehousing, mental health, together as one San Francisco. The mission. I can remember my mom taking me to all India Maria movies at the Mission Theater. I can remember Valencia Street, when it was nothing for the long stretch of appliance stores, leather tongue video in the chameleon bar.
作为同龄的年轻人，再往前迈一步，看看背后的原因。我要再投入五亿美元用于导航中心的即时资金。所以我们需要作为一个整体共同努力。这是快速安置住房、心理健康，作为一个统一的旧金山共同努力。教会区。我还记得妈妈带我去教会剧院看所有印第安玛丽亚的电影。我还记得瓦伦西亚街，当时那一长片电器店、皮革店、变色龙酒吧之间什么都没有。
I can remember the payphone. My name is Josiah Lise Alderete, full-blooded, bocho, indio, Spanish-speaking poet, raised here in La Ria Bahia, bread and spread throughout the mission. My mom and papa met at the famous Cinelloan Mexican Spanish nightclub, which was at the time in the middle of the Mexican barrio, the Mexican neighborhood, which is, you know, north beach. My dad was working at the Cinelloan nightclub and you know, they were those high-waisted, wader jackets back there, tight like, got a yellow pants you know,
我还记得那个公用电话。我叫约西亚·利斯·阿尔德雷特，纯血统的、波奇奥人、印第安人、说西班牙语的诗人，在拉里亚巴希亚长大，在教会区生根发芽并四处开枝散叶。我的父母在著名的西内洛安墨西哥西班牙语夜总会相遇，当时它位于墨西哥巴里奥（墨西哥街区）的中心，也就是你知道的，北滩。我爸爸当时在西内洛安夜总会工作，你知道的，那时候他们穿着那种高腰的、涉水裤一样的夹克，紧绷着，你知道的，还有黄色的裤子，
and live music, big orchestra. I can remember George Dirado. I can remember Daniel Alacón. I can remember that Sonia Sanchez has walked these streets. I can remember the Nancy Modejón has walked these streets. I can remember Alfonso Textador's limp. People associate the comm waves of gentrification. It's been going on since before the 2000s.
现场音乐，大乐队。我还记得乔治·迪拉多。我还记得丹尼尔·阿拉孔。我还记得桑尼娅·桑切斯曾走过这些街道。我还记得南希·莫德洪曾走过这些街道。我还记得阿方索·特斯塔多的跛足。人们将中产阶级化的浪潮联系在一起。这在2000年代之前就已经开始了。
You know, I remember first seeing that wave, there was the oxygen bar opened up on Valencia Street. And you know, also we started seeing these big puffy SUV vehicles around it. I remember so that I can get out of the way of the ubers and the lifts and the Google buses that are not driving me anywhere someplace. The changes that have been the most startling and physical and painful to see in the neighborhood have definitely come from the .com changes in Google. But, you know, on the flip side of that, the Guugula is really dug in, you know.
你知道，我记得第一次看到那种浪潮，瓦伦西亚街上开了一家氧气吧。而且你知道的，我们周围也开始看到那些高大饱满的SUV车辆。我记得，这样我就可以避开那些并没有载我去任何地方的优步（Uber）、来福车（Lyft）和谷歌巴士。在社区里看到的那些最惊人、最直观、最痛苦的改变，绝对来自.com时代的变化和谷歌。但是，你知道，另一方面，谷歌真的已经扎根了，你知道的。
I mean, giving the 24-scree declared a Latino heritage corridor, that protects like a huge amount of those areas. There's amazing transformations in the mission with the Coyote de Cuatro Association reaching out. So a lot of the older generation, a lot of the older ones are really, sort of, recommitted to staying. It's actually a beautiful thing. When people move here and they come here and they think of the city,
我是说，宣布24街为拉丁裔文化遗产走廊，这保护了这些地区绝大部分的面积。随着四月之友协会的伸出援手，教会区发生了惊人的变革。因此，很多老一代人，很多老一辈人真的可以说是重新承诺留下来。这其实是一件很美好的事情。当人们搬到这里并来到这里，他们想到这座城市时，
what they're thinking of is the contributions of the poets and the working people have made to this city. Well, I'd like to see happen some sacred space opening up for people to move back in and raise their families. As much as the city does change, those roots are gonna stay, they're way deep in the concrete. That's the bones of this place.
他们想到的是诗人和劳动者为这座城市做出的贡献。嗯，我希望看到的是为人们搬回来并抚养家庭开辟出一些神圣的空间。尽管这座城市确实在改变，但这些根基将会留存下来，它们深深扎根于混凝土之中。那是这个地方的骨骼。
I live where you make a shine. Moving through the city. Here's Justin Vivian Bond, 2012. My name's Justin Vivian Bond. I sing, I write and perform. A trans genre artist. I used to live in San Francisco, I lived there from 88 to 94. And the two things that drove me crazy about San Francisco were the weather, which many people love, but which I hate.
我住在你闪耀的地方。穿梭于城市之中。这位是贾斯汀·维维安·邦德，2012年。我叫贾斯汀·维维安·邦德。我唱歌、写作和表演。跨性别流派艺术家。我曾经住在旧金山，从88年到94年我一直住在那里。旧金山有两件事让我快要发疯，一是天气，许多人很喜欢，但我却讨厌。
Let me preface all of it by saying, I adore San Francisco. I love living there. If there's any city where I would feel like there are more people that I would have Thanksgiving or Christmas with, San Francisco is the one. But having said that, I don't like the weather and I always got very, very frustrated by transportation because I was at the mercy of the taxi cabs of San Francisco and they're notoriously unreliable. So, I came back to San Francisco. I guess it was for my record release. I was getting my hair blown out,
首先我要声明，我非常崇拜旧金山。我喜欢住在那里。如果说有哪个城市让我觉得有更多的人可以一起过感恩节或圣诞节，那非旧金山莫属。但话虽如此，我并不喜欢那里的天气，而且交通也总是让我感到非常非常沮丧，因为我得任由旧金山的出租车摆布，而它们出了名的不可靠。所以，我回到了旧金山。我想那是为了我的唱片发行。我在瓦伦西亚街的
the Dina's glamorama on Valencia. My friend said, Lini Breedlove has started homeobile. Call if you need a ride. And so I told them where I was and I needed a car. They said, I think it was Musty Shafan. Yes, it was Musty Shafan.
迪娜魅力沙龙做头发。我的朋友说，里尼·布里德洛夫创办了“家门车”（Homeobiles）。如果你需要车就打电话。所以我告诉他们我在哪里，我需要一辆车。他们说，我想那是穆斯蒂·沙凡。是的，就是穆斯蒂·沙凡。
She showed up and was my driver. So all of a sudden this person who I had known in clubs, we were driving in a car and talking with each other. They asked for a suggested donation and of course you just want to give them the entire contents of your pocketbook because they're so lovely. See what I tell you. Trapack. My name is Leningrad Love.
她出现了，成了我的司机。所以突然之间，这个我曾在俱乐部里认识的人，我们坐在一辆车里互相交谈。他们要求给一点建议捐款，当然你只想把钱包里的所有东西都掏给他们，因为他们太可爱了。看我怎么跟你说。Trapack。我叫列宁格勒·爱。
I run Homebills, a community ride service for the LGBTQL and the WPQST community and at Dallas and San Francisco. You do not have to be a big back queer to get a ride from home bills, but it does help. No, just kidding. But you need to understand that the real reason that we are here is for people that don't get rides normally from anyone else. And so, if you're putting on all this padding, high heels, a wig, and three sets of fall-style lashes, and a bunch of glitter, you are high priority at whole bills. If we're thinking about the most effective way to get people through cities, we should look at how different systems move people. Transit, you can move up to 25,000 people per hour through a city if they're on public transit. Walking actually comes after that and you could move approximately 9,000 people per hour through a city on foot.
我经营“家门车”，这是为LGBTQL和WPQST社群以及达拉斯和旧金山的社区乘车服务。你不一定非得是个大个儿酷儿才能从“家门车”搭车，但那样确实会有帮助。不，开玩笑的。但你需要明白，我们来到这里的真正原因是为了那些通常无法从其他人那里搭到车的人。所以，如果你盛装打扮，穿着厚厚的衬垫、高跟鞋、假发、三套假睫毛，还涂抹了一堆亮片，你在“家门车”就是最高优先级。如果我们考虑将人们运送穿过城市的最高效方式，我们应该看看不同的系统是如何运送人们的。公共交通，如果人们乘坐公共交通，你可以在一小时内将多达25,000人运送穿过一座城市。步行实际上排在后面，你大约可以在一小时内步行将9,000人运送穿过一座城市。
Biking, moving about 7,500 people per hour. Cars can only move about 600 to 1600 people per hour. 1600 people per hour. At a very young age, we took the bussus all over town, to get a municipal card with 10 rides. It was five cents a ride, and they would punch a hole to use it up. We used that to get to go downtown, to Market Street, and we used it to go to Plainland. Plainland in the beach, it was just a classic ocean,
骑自行车，每小时运送大约7,500人。汽车每小时只能运送大约600到1600人。每小时1600人。在很小的时候，我们就坐着公交车去城里的各处，去买一张有10次乘车额度的市政卡。每趟五分钱，他们会打个洞来用掉次数。我们用它去市中心，去市场街，我们用它去普莱兰。海滩边的普莱兰，它只是一个经典的海滨、
front, prominent playground, wonderfully dangerous physical attractions. Running through this barrel that kept turning. The barrel of joy. You walked into the barrel of joy, and it rotated, and it was padded, and it would drop you on your head. A laughing soul, she really freaked me out. I had a lot of nightmares about her freckled face and red hair.
显眼的游乐场，有着奇妙而危险的实体游乐设施。穿过这个不断旋转的桶。快乐之桶。你走进快乐之桶，它会旋转，里面有软垫，会把你摔到头上。一个大笑的灵魂，她真的把我吓坏了。我做了很多关于她满脸雀斑和红头发的噩梦。
Confusing mirrors. You'd be fat, you'd be tall, you'd be squished. Jets of compressed air. That they would release under the skirts of women and girls as they came in. The wheel of joy was a huge wooden platter that spun. They blow the whistle and everyone would crowd and get their butts as close as possible to the center, the centrifugal force, to pick them off. They go sailing off.
让人眼花缭乱的镜子。你会变胖，变高，被挤压。压缩空气喷射。每当女性和女孩走进来时，他们就会在她们的裙子底下释放这种压缩空气。快乐之轮是一个巨大的、会旋转的木质圆盘。他们一吹哨，所有人就会蜂拥而至，尽量把屁股贴近中心，利用离心力把他们甩飞。他们就被抛飞出去了。
It fell on hard times and they tore it down and put up these got-offal condos that stand there now. I got to clean the Strobaz and Playland much to the consternation of other people cleaning the model those days. It's such a coveted place to clean and it was definitely fun to run the Q-tip down the shoots of Playland. I also got to clean the Laurel Hill Cemetery, which no longer exists along Geary. This big expanse of multiple blocks with trees and pathways, and that tells the story of the removal of the Cemetery from San Francisco to Colma and down the peninsula where all of our bodies go now. BEEP.
它遭遇了不景气的时期，他们把它拆了，盖上了现在立在那里的那些糟糕的公寓楼。我有机会清理普莱兰的斯特罗巴兹，这让当时清理模型的其他人感到非常惊讶。这是一个多么令人垂涎的清理地方啊，用棉签清理普莱兰的滑梯绝对是一件很有趣的事。我还清理了桂树山公墓，它已经沿着吉里大道不复存在了。这片横跨多个街区的开阔地带有树木和小径，它讲述了将墓园从旧金山迁移到科尔马以及半岛下方（我们所有人的遗体现在去的地方）的故事。哔。
BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP.
哔。哔。哔。哔。哔|||哔。哔。哔。
BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP.
哔。哔。哔。哔。哔。哔。哔。哔。哔。
BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. BEEP. library. And I look at this model, so you can see all the different green houses. This was a major center of flower growing, carnations and roses. Since we're the garden district, people they would love it to be kind of a hub for green activity like gardening, community garden, bicycles, walking, trolleys, the air would be so light. I'm curious what this looks like in 800 years. Will the third great quake scare us away? Now we're going to be here till the bitter end. So what's the plan? I would like to see more emphasis on the greenery.
图书馆。我看着这个模型，所以你可以看到所有不同的温室。这里是鲜花种植的主要中心，种植康乃馨和玫瑰。既然我们是花园区，人们会希望这里成为绿色活动的中心，比如园艺、社区花园、自行车、步行、有轨电车，空气会变得如此清新。我很好奇800年后这里会是什么样子。第三次大地震会把我们吓跑吗？现在我们要在这里待到最后一刻。那计划是什么？我希望看到更多对绿化的重视。
I would envision building up rather than out and raise the density. I don't want my rises. No, my rises. The roads are ridiculously wide. There's a good amount of wasted space in the sunset. Space that's more fresh as now and could be used. We're in college and like. Would this be before or after the sun up? Yeah, right there.
我设想向上发展而不是向外扩展，并提高人口密度。我不想建高层。不，我的高层。道路宽得离谱。日落区有相当一部分浪费的空间。现在更新鲜、可以利用的空间。我们在上大学的时候。这会在日出之前还是之后？对，就在那儿。
It would be really great to see this San Francisco model. There's a whole and to do ongoing programming, hearing people's stories. I'd like to see it under Plexi class that you could just walk on top of and just lay down and look at like protected, but free so that you could really get in. The city's all changed and have to change
能看到这个旧金山模型真是太棒了。有一个整体，并且开展持续的节目，倾听人们的故事。我希望看到它被放在有机玻璃下面，你可以直接在上面行走，甚至躺下来看，就像受到保护一样，但又是自由的，这样你就可以真正融入其中。城市一直在变，也必须改变
and anyone who wants to keep it frozen and wax so that if forever looks like 1930 at model is the illusion all in is going to be disappointed. This is the issue that everyone's trying to grapple with for this city is how do we preserve it in all of its glory but at the same time make places dynamic as possible and have make it as hospitable as possible. It won't look exactly like the 1938 model. It won't even look like the 2019 version. And I think that there's a way of achieving it without losing what makes it special. Hopefully we can make a start. Well, it seems there are the beginnings of a new consciousness in a new generation of activists in San Francisco. And it seems to be a kind of wave of a future with a new coalition of young progressives.
任何想要把它像蜡一样冻结起来，好让它永远看起来像1930年那个模型的人，都是在幻想，最终都会失望。这是每个人都在努力为这座城市解决的问题，即我们如何在保持其所有辉煌的同时，尽可能地让地方充满活力，并使其尽可能地好客。它不会完全看起来像1938年的模型。它甚至不会看起来像2019年的版本。而且我认为有一种方法可以实现这一点，而不会失去让它变得特别的东西。希望我们能开个好头。嗯，在旧金山的新一代活动人士中，似乎正萌生着一种新的意识。这似乎是一种未来的浪潮，伴随着由年轻进步主义者组成的新联盟。
That includes not only the Green Movement but also groups like the Bicycle Coalition with its vision of a carless city, alternative cultural institutions. There are also poetic rappers, seniors for peace, and performance artists, farmers market selling local produce, raising the possibility of a self-sustaining ecoregent, free from ecologically disastrous angry business. It's a vision of a possible future society in America, but of course, it's yet to be realized,
这不仅包括绿色运动，还包括诸如自行车联盟等团体，它们有着无车城市的愿景、另类的文化机构。还有诗意的说唱歌手、和平老人和行为艺术家、出售当地农产品的农夫市场，这带来了实现一个自给自足的生态区域的可能性，摆脱了生态灾难性的愤怒生意的困扰。这是对美国未来可能出现的一种社会愿景，当然，它尚未实现，
but it does exist in our consciousness. San Francisco's stories from the model city was produced by the kitchen sisters Nikki Silva and Davia Nelson with Nathan Dalton and Brandy Howell mixed by Jim McKee. The kitchen sisters presents is their podcast from radio toopia. Please go subscribe, download all the old episodes. You will love them. Soundscapes and archival audio from Jim McKee and Andrew Roth, additional recordings by Noah Landis, Grant MacAmir, and from SFLOMA's Public Knowledge Program take part, in which the
但它确实存在于我们的意识中。“旧金山：来自模型城市的故事”由厨房姐妹尼基·希尔瓦（Nikki Silva）和达维亚·纳尔逊（Davia Nelson）与内森·道尔顿（Nathan Dalton）和布兰迪·豪威尔（Brandy Howell）共同制作，吉姆·麦基（Jim McKee）混音。“厨房姐妹呈献”是他们来自 Radiotopia 的播客。请去订阅，下载所有旧节目。你会爱上它们的。声景和档案音频来自吉姆·麦基和安德鲁·罗斯，额外录音由诺亚·兰迪斯（Noah Landis）、格兰特·麦克阿米尔（Grant MacAmir）以及 SFMOMA 的公众知识计划“参与”（Take Part）提供，在该项目中，
museum partnered with the San Francisco Public Library and artist's Big Fender Pull to engage the community in a series of talks and events around the model of San Francisco. Thanks to Tomoko Konomietsu's Stella Lachman, Aaron Fleming, Valerie Wainwright, Kevin Carr, Erica Gancy, and the entire take part in raw material project teams. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in Deep thanks to author Gary Camea, keeper of the model Stella Lachman, Dr. Gray Brecken, UC Berkeley and the Living New Deal, poet Lawrence Firlingettie, poet Jenny Lim. Our bicycle historians and activists Lisa Ruth Elliott and Chris Carlson of Shaping San Francisco, artist's Big Vendor Pull, excerpts Maya Angelou's I Know Why the Cage Bird
博物馆与旧金山公共图书馆以及艺术家大供应商拉扯（Big Fender Pull）合作，围绕旧金山模型开展了一系列讲座和活动，让社区参与其中。感谢友松智子（Tomoko Konomietsu）、斯特拉·拉奇曼（Stella Lachman）、亚伦·弗莱明（Aaron Fleming）、瓦莱丽·温赖特（Valerie Wainwright）、凯文·卡尔（Kevin Carr）、埃里卡·甘西（Erica Gancy）以及整个“参与”和原材料项目团队。[背景音乐播放]
sings read by the author used by permission of Penguin Random House Audio Publishing Group. Teacher and historian Jarelle Phillips, Ellison Arieth, Spur Think Tank, Naima Dean, Western Edition Branch Library, Food Rider Peggy Nicarbocker, courtesy of Porchlight Storytelling Series. Poet, Chazaya Luis Alderready, Nicole, Termini, Germtelling series. Poet, Chazaya Luis Alderready. Nicole, Termini, Germaine, Portola Branch Library. Peggy Millett, courtesy of the Irish American Crossroads Oral History Archive, performer Justin Vivian Bond.
歌唱》，由作者本人朗读，经企鹅兰登书屋音频出版集团许可使用。教师兼历史学家贾雷尔·菲利普斯（Jarelle Phillips）、埃莉森·阿里斯（Ellison Arieth，Spur智库）、内玛·迪恩（Naima Dean，西方版分图书馆）、美食作家佩吉·尼卡巴克，由 Porchlight 讲故事系列提供。诗人查扎亚·路易斯·阿尔德雷蒂（Chazaya Luis Alderready）、妮可·特米尼（Nicole Termini）、日耳曼，波托拉分图书馆。佩吉·米利特（Peggy Millett），由爱尔兰裔美国人十字路口口述历史档案馆提供，表演者贾斯汀·维维安·邦德。
Lenny Breedlove, founder of Home Obieos, and thanks to the Internet Archive and the Kitchen Sisters Archive. For our music we thank Blue Dot Sessions, SoulTrend from San Francisco's Mission District, Ted Severese, Richard Feno, John Zhang, Nathan Dalton, B.S.W. Polgagelski, and Jim McKee. And to all the citizens, librarians, and keepers who took part in the model project throughout San Francisco, we thank you. And yes, you can see the model online. Go to takepartsf.net, zoom in and find your favorite spots.
列宁·布里德洛夫（Lenny Breedlove），“家门车”创始人，并感谢互联网档案馆和厨房姐妹档案馆。对于我们的音乐，我们感谢 Blue Dot Sessions、来自旧金山教会区的 SoulTrend、泰德·塞弗雷斯（Ted Severese）、理查德·费诺（Richard Feno）、张约翰（John Zhang）、内森·道尔顿（Nathan Dalton）、B.S.W. 波尔加格尔斯基（B.S.W. Polgagelski）和吉姆·麦基。以及所有参与旧金山模型项目的市民、图书管理员和守护者，我们感谢你们。是的，你可以在网上看到这个模型。访问 takepartsf.net，放大并找到你最喜欢的地方。
And while you're up there, sign the petition to find a permanent home for San Francisco in San Francisco. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRXF, the Independent Collective of Ground Breaking Podcast. Find them all at radtopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or run Instagram and read it too. But our forever home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio tapio.
当你浏览时，请签署请愿书，为旧金山在旧金山找到一个永久的家。“99%可听见”是 PRX 旗下 Radotopia 的成员，Radotopia 是开创性播客的独立集体。请访问 radtopia.fm 查找所有这些播客。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于该节目的讨论，你可以在 Twitter 上@罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）并在节目中@99PI，或者也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上关注我们。但我们在网络上的永久家园是 99PI.org。Radio tapio。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。